[Music]
in huge scandal news oh yeah another one
another one handles we need to take a
scandal break there should be like a law
that goes all right to many scandals
right now we just shell out everybody or
like a scandal quiz I need a scandal
[ __ ]
I like scandals cuz that means people
are finally getting caught for their
booze [ __ ] that's kinda cool too you
just won against me Jesus was just like
I don't want to hear it right Jake again
Coppa I don't want to hear it cuz I'm
saying yeah I just thought the Joe I
don't hear submitted by Lee and Carter
oh [ __ ] and Carter oh yeah they're
coming here town huh they're gonna play
I'm gonna plant the Microsoft theater
rush-hour Lee and car come see I thought
it was Nick Carter's little brother or
you may like Leanne Carter yeah I don't
know federal prosecutors have charged
dozens and a college admissions cheating
see yeah yeah we've been knowing about
[ __ ] like this no no it's also
surprising because there was so many
celebrities like we knew this [ __ ] was
happening that Becky
pin yeah her [ __ ] her a listers it's
still way way way away you guys knew
that people were paying to get their
kids in school and lying and that it was
assumed no no but they they do it in
legal ways so this is what people assume
well most people is you know like let's
say you're super rich you want your kids
to get into Harvard or one of the eight
or whatever right yeah you donate money
to the library you just donate money to
the school all these things and that's
the normal way to bribe someone because
that's the legal way you donate but then
there's other ways where people secure
it by train up well this is a story I'll
let you tell the story well and then
some people just pay the eighty dollar
application fee and get good grades yeah
but then they get pushed away from these
cheaters like this that's true yep so
these two actresses
they're kind of like the face of the
scandal there's 50 people I think that
were that are on the lawsuit or
something yeah there's the most 50
people that they yeah we've arrested but
these are the most famous so yeah so uh
it's Lori Loughlin so yeah at Becky and
then the Desperate Housewives
actress Felicity Huffman well was she
from Aunt Becky she was so hot Oh John
stain luck in uncle Jesse's wife so what
she did do she's still hot
ya know yep so there's two parts to this
ski or like there's two ways that this
ringleader would cheat these kids to go
into these Ivy League schools and one of
the ways which is what Lori did Oscar
the Ivy Lee well not all of them okay
well did it for her it was Essie yeah I
just got a donate dude I know so many
people that just donated some [ __ ] that
got in oh maybe the donation is too much
like it's like four hundred thousand
they're like ain't that rich no more
full house ain't on air so then it's
like all you got Coolio for like 30
grand or some [ __ ] like they didn't
maybe like if your parents donate then
kids a school know that you just got in
because your parents don't even or
low-key way of doing they don't know
though that's the thing so I went to a
military school and then this kid
Blake's that he probably had C or D
grades the whole time and it was to the
point where so even in that school just
like clout gets you a long way because
it is a private school so his parents
already donate to that school and this
fool was so are worded
when regular homework this will got to
turn in homework with crayons and
drawings so like instead of like a Civil
War report he gets to just draw a
picture of two guys fighting each other
with a crayon
this is how much they lower the bar
front so he could step over and then I
went back to like an alumni gathering
and I was a whole place down I what you
gonna do after everyone's graduating you
know a lot I got into SC I'm like what
how the [ __ ] you get and it was all my
dad don't had a bunch of computers to
the computer that Oh see that's like a
like nice specific targeted donation
though like I feel like that's like you
know that's sentimental it's a little
bit wedding cash like
no a couple computers got some backup
well that's what they do they do they
put new plants up they do whatever and
no one they'll hey and when they're when
they're having dinner with their buddy
that's the Dean or the Chancellor or
whatever they just go hey I don't want
to pause full name and period
Blake's that is gonna be applying can
you keep a lookout for him but what
happens when they actually have to go to
school that's a we were saying like USC
it's like are you gonna drop out like
you can't but yeah that's super possible
to or the clout keeps pushing them all
the way through like I got what's UCLA
alright it's a Division one athletic
school and when I'm in class with a lot
of athletes they can do all kinds if see
at least are different though because
they're their goal in there is to make
that school look good through the
athletic program Lori did so she cheated
her kids so she paid five hundred
thousand dollars in bribes for her two
daughters five hundred thousand at the
legal way but most of the people that
get in they're getting through athletics
that's what I was trying to say is that
she got her two daughters to pretend
like they were part of the the crew team
oh yeah there's a rolling crew there's
tennis teams there's like there's a
whole bunch of coaches I got caught in
this there's a lot of like Proctor's
that got caught in this and yeah so
that's what Lori did for her two
daughters but then Felicity she ended up
just donating to the ringleaders charity
but in reality she was paying for
someone to for someone to take the test
for her kid Daniela hello oh that's just
straight cheating yeah
they probably don't know my avenues
that's right
pass me the donating computers to her
computer oh I think everyone knows that
but this one secures it yeah so for
example Felicity she paid fifteen
thousand dollars to that big charity and
her daughter received four hundred
points higher on the PSAT than what she
had taken before they change her answers
they're manipulating the system behind
closed so so it's not like you donate
half a million dollars to the school and
they're like yeah all right they
probably don't have the
Klout or connection so they still want
their kids to go to these schools that
got you so and it's cheaper to it's
anywhere from 15,000 to 80,000 and in so
I think that number you said earlier
it's like the toll right so it's a total
amount but they're also paying a bunch
of other things outside of that but so
what they'll do is like they'll like
they'll they'll get like a school tennis
coach or whatever to do you know
cooperate and team up with them they'll
get other students to take the tests
though Photoshop you know their pictures
in athlete teams they'll boost up their
fake resumes say that they got this
grade or whatever Photoshop then what
happens when they got a run they just
get a body double how much you got to
pay the body I think they just bench
them yeah there's a lot to it there's a
lot of time this is so bad yeah but
there's a lot of different ways that
they game the system but basically it's
based off of one dude who makes these
promises he gets him in he gets results
so rich and powerful people go oh [ __ ]
easy let's go let's do it I'll pay that
money but the way he's doing it is he
has a nonprofit organization that should
look like Warren Buffett's brother on
the Left you don't have to worry about
like the stress of paying tuition you
don't have to worry about the stress of
like actually running the marathon you
don't have to worry about getting in or
anything and then you're just a [ __ ]
like stress builds character like you
need that a little bit like you need
attention you need own Tory's daughters
she has a she a bit tough and she would
be pretty much saying like yeah well I
mean you know I'm looking forward to
going to the parties and looking forward
for this but you guys already know I
don't like school like well that's like
she's kind of like rubbing it in now
that we know everyone she she kind of
made she kind of capitalized on the
lifestyle of being a student and she's a
successful youtuber by living the
lifestyle and getting brand deals and
like exploiting the college student life
so she's getting famous off of that and
building her own persona off of just
being a student but she doesn't actually
do this
didn't work so she's getting more
successful doing that then than being a
student does this mean she's gonna put
out an apology video I know right cuz I
want to watch that already it's not even
shot yet Oh what does she look like
beautiful yeah they just look like what
I see cuz I want to see how much I hate
them based on how they look subscribe
basic college white girls blonde that go
to Starbucks all the time to study with
ugg boots on I think the mom's blonde
right yeah they're brunette oh let me
see this [ __ ] so I could judge the [ __ ]
out of these [ __ ] I would just like
to see them to know what they look like
I'm curious why they don't just do they
look like that girl at USC seriously
it's like this is the older one
oh looks like one of the Kardashian what
is that Kylie Kylie before the surgery
right yeah yeah yeah you're cute though
pretty yeah they're cute I expected
bitchier I've had a lot of celebrities
like I'm kind of confused I've thought a
lot of celebrity people once they make
it pretty big like on full house or
whatever they they feel like they're
above school like they don't have to go
so my thing is too if you have half a
million dollars right yeah why do they
have to go to school yeah at that point
you know what I mean because I think we
don't know cuz we're not part of that
group you know we're like we're like way
beneath them like this excuse people for
yourself who we don't we're like all the
way down here no we're like up here I
mean we're like down here maybe in their
groups they care about like you know
like the connection to me if I have a
half a million [ __ ] dollars just to
give out I would tell my kids you don't
got to do [ __ ] you just got to be a
decent human being take this [ __ ]
money and go do something and like
invest in a company like the designer
that's because I think it might be an
ego thing for the mom too because would
you rather say oh my daughter's an
entrepreneur or would you rather say oh
she's up she's at Harvard like you know
it might you didn't even go to Harvard
she went to SC no shape to se folks how
[ __ ] dare you dude that's these
Trojans for life charlie just provide
for sure but it seems like the West
Coast Harvard I know I think Dad first a
West Coast Harvard staff yeah I guess so
but they're bird they're both up there I
heard they charge seven except non zero
fees only because you
see okay like put it this way like I
could academics wise it's not like
Stanford right but prestige wise and and
like let rich people wise if you think
about that like if you think of Ivy
League is is known for the networking
like their alumni is faulting strong
that's what I mean by it's like the west
coast's Harvard right it's it's not
built on merit it's there's a lot of
people that are just rich as [ __ ] that
get in so like what what's the Ivy
League equivalent on the west coast
that's full of people that are kind of
like us aristocrats Yeah right there's
really no other school it's either you
go to the the Ivy League's in the East
Coast or you go to USC you know it's
really disappointing when you meet
somebody who goes to like Ivy League
school and you find out after the fact
you already concluded that they're dumb
how did you get in there dude
it's a war looking stupid you also you
know how there is that controversy about
like how Asians can't get in and there's
a lot of people that work [ __ ] hard
to get in Ivy League's right but they
have these rules in place to let like
these rich people get in first so like
if you have legacy in that school you
get priority if you donate to that
school you get priority so like let's
say if your great-grandparents went to
that school and your grandparent and
your [ __ ] dad everybody went to that
school then your tip top on the list if
your indie and you get a priority to
that [ __ ] works
whenever I'm like if I'm feeling out
like a job thing or like some kind of
benefits it'll say like ethnicity and
I'm checkoff black and then I'm like
also American Indian Dan you get all and
your woman to you're going to get all of
that take it all
[Music]